[Music]  Reverend dick out away a retired  Episcopal minister was a Renaissance man  religious about reading his newspapers  every morning and faithful about feeding  the wild birds he loved to watch around  his Massachusetts home he was an  intellectual his stepson in law JT  Rogers recalled erudite knew about food  and wine and the Bible richard napoleon  otto a grew up in rural North Carolina  and was the first in his family to go to  college he became a chaplain at Wake  Forest University and traveled the world  in England where he was a professor of  business ethics he met his wife Elaine  their home on Cape Cod was a gathering  place open for everyone Ottaway  stepdaughter rebecca ashley recalled the  family did not get to say goodbye to  reverend not away in the hospital for a  minister ashley said who ministered to  so many people in their last hours not  to be with him was really hard  reverend dick ottawa was 88  [Music]